[music]
[applause]
thank you for coming now in oberwerrn
experience the emotions convinced the
austria oscar theory now sits and it's
going on the rating realities left just
this office ingrid liebig distinction and
it's wonderful to celebrate  this
change takes place here in this very people
who are contributing to contribute to
get my collaborating hasso people who
have mentoring and have critical support
moment in front of the label moment photo mig
physics sits integrated moment in front of
oliver are familiar with the reality from the
mini mini pcs displays hardware icon
allen karl university of colorado and we
weren't are they early no the is
henry huge to boards kohl the
temperature are hunting for that has
been the best competition of my life and
ultimately the device is everyone de is
now whether he cares about a virus  the x-men
trilogy newfield either temple
recognition should i am were
collegiate are then ran excellent
reviews
now  am i early
antiquity hesse long history and shot
off fireworks daniel of the state deposited in the
early 90 seventies of
handy the plumber trying bose
einstein condensation of thommy
screeching the tomic in was really just
not that would be the one that came the
people the man dem  dave richards
retired reader cooling and open
the uk prospect people something the
merger profile will or big break before
a reality privilege john terry in
the early no this privilege to
complete the mountains ntt com
the oxide large individual accounts
at the dsb special ez if the
electric field comic physics cent pose
einstein condensation with combative
a share in paris included meet
it goes straight mission before oliver are
a newlyweds
bose einstein condensation is in new
form of murder now special form of
marriage form ceo is temperature steve
rogers to address to the people  young
peregrine falcon walks to the back of
the cottage lit  tle fockers im millimeter
submillimeter saas cloud office nothing
but we get excited because it special
properties the sample consists of
million for the evaluation sandy leddin loks
bissingen july this very special
form of which is very special properties
and by discovering studies form is supposed to come alive
meter we learn more  about nature at the
sweetest first reward for physis for
discover new form of magic new
properties juve die flug into the beauty
of nature and is in this form of
magic cities of special sprit
implications and some of them baby in
the broke to the session form  of media
and used for precision measurement in front of
concrete blocks from nanotechnology mediven in
front of noble form on computation quantum
computation vista job gills the group's
worldwide to explore the finger on
the possible but it is typical for
fundamental research note is including
images i knew quality and numerous
possibilities  which can be x.de win the
tour complete with lg red spider
bose einstein condensation where it is
before toms input material particle system
step decision counters with sorrow if the
reader steals what
euro notes difference between the light
bulb mendel sabine will discovery in
the celebration in the tomic physics systems
over indiana of light box homely
tomic light bulb race like
moving valovis data how much shaped early
no the five me on the austria toms
economic activity properties se reader
lr tom smith in loxstedt heini direction
lb immo value us as instance as the merging of the atom
will be what the
complete optical reader development
revolution bar tomic for six exchange
tvr  tomic physics system creative and of
course like pike research area strip
impact bat the nobel prize is possible so
extraordinary networking demands this
sword of something is the foremost figure
what mer khamis simon clarified how
does the section both good
physics as an interpreter cheerfulness the celebration
something in  new form of  murder by its
impact well emergency loans that covers today
a word happened in dallas texas is
only more is research group are maurice
group fx blue the disco form of matter
and have shown the ts mini special
properties it can be used for many
fundamental studies in physics  and
libraries first steps to build meter
path sensors news source red bull impact
of discovery at the few years for that
we come decibel
avery specific prediction willi prosen
case much criticism bot it happened in the
last few years but i don't want the
question that  general this quality
also readers leader tom sawyer basic
building blocks of nature and we now
have an president control over this
building blocks of nature this time so good
before not institute for many things
we can't even drink your word people
the casting is unite news  at home
center post them on services in fine
pattern are war amano devices of
the future the people think this at home
sweet slade in loxstedt m  inivan julie
bible clockwork on noble computers and
usd away because he's elias is in
exploration and the future picture herbert
concert at this the buzzwords
nanotechnology new form of computation
new ad hoc locos and
networks questions for the telephone of the
dating agency had some top parts of the
possible  so high time prepare a
condensate some cars in sentosa super flu
e10 superconductor in the moss family
superconductor swear electrician karins
recognizes flow regrets the end of the epic
super contact and was yes that noted
in the bose einstein condensate similar
properties the thoms can be in motion
according to friction regrets  slow down super
contact super flu song i see the world
super because there's something special
treat in the bose einstein condensate is
the most fundamente example in visp on
superstar so is coherence apps are so
friction super bee this painting technique
awards at the buzz words with very
special  properties
[music]
okay the question  is about how he
got direct from the reader particles are hood
credit if the bus could see what was
discovered in the finals or that wasn't
raab holt cloud people would have started
directly rally martin lures step and
this is the most important property or
readers of the one  in the case of light is
one big electromagnetic wave in the case
of homes now apparently meter wave
and if like real estate to readers about
ebel to georgia street owes the
tom's condensed in depots
arrived flaig and second liedgut created first
rudimentary error readers with heavy metal
stripping cars you could change
talks at gravity and formed first
posing atomic at scan energy with
laser beam switcher co your teams of
light are senna group sap already
creative direction lm lesers still have to
the wind group picture philips eversberg
cinema gloria leser calling for years
ago next  winter research is to use
condenses test fundamental physics to
realize motives in the saddle du form  s of
media experiments w3 putbus condenses
and tips and micro fabricate services
so who is am hope that we can create
the future atom chips who in new
ordinary chips the information carried
at elektrons moving in wernau motto
creates atom chips who tom smith close
to  service center ground as well as talking
about next major statement new
perspectives a lot was built
[music]
the water prize some story behind moan
morning something professor
the secretary of the swedish academy of
sciences where does me here together
imports used to date for this offers
risk but this is here  nobel prize
theater question what we lose yes
now hobby cyclist unusual research is
record champion steve julius respected
discovery at the sphinx reflex mini
kollegs world wide web edi picking up &
development and estimates ins no the
5000 scientific research papers
catherine advised therefore register lot
so worldwide of the activities of  hundreds
of scientists and than in discos rese  arch
and impact as revolution bar
tomic physics to research out of anger with the time
and many of my colleagues noted the
dis is important end of this promising
advance exploration development
before the computer and the research is
about all tractors and alcohol - apps
are very slow and lives  heaven
advantage in speed because addons movies
order michael lightning bolt but says
some hope to use of homes from new wave
computation so quantum computers not
necessarily faster in terms of the clock
speed of just much more efficiently
perel processing with the heavy pairs
left with max in the integrated  chips like
lead to his new class of
quantum computers remains to be seen
this year on atom chips is rio
licensed promising directly tries
ok bose einstein condensate character
tears at cambridge it in the nano
calvin regimes the murder a million
times cola the interstellar space
together part up to  his in uk
white cabbage the after 2001 colonies of the dfb
very  phenomena physics are noble
properties of which way to go even kohl
rand should sony if we had the
choice whether techniques you cool modern
million times noah because the temple job
interstellar space the top twelve this
form on meters the independent faz
boulder using rubidium atoms juso die  about
something about four workshops experiments
for several years an investor remark
apple is like that of the finance boss group
sexy the something in june the perpetrator break
where in boulder in september
yes
[music]
[applause]
different mai there we got this
morning we want to  go to school speech
there shoots because we are so with holger is
a sold and roll garching memorial
quote was still to reporters at the best
thing about my day training the
nobel prize is don't have to go of the
cultural heritage jonas 17 years old and
he said  problem high school has getting
your personal or steve pritchard east
and africa next to me because it really
speaks vorhauser mrt system acts die
hat mir sein po  ster named in the
more positive philo physics and i was in
the cold recommends who am i supposed
to be learned from him may the free
software poster came to many things you
can't take my live the union a tool
the leather with discovered bose einstein
condensates and the sword of execute
inge came the gender person and
tv commentator long blocked the
service team
[applause]
hingis reality all the people who can
the werkelt tenants come up and down
this moment with me
[applause]
acutely introduce the body individual and
this completely münster the city
fantastic team a compliment
install choir to work with people
speak for the explosively large infield
turn research bosnian each of the
economic master elf went to cradle
story 3 des dudens ending team was
crying at the maker for different  ways
to explore the new possibilities bed
relevance ugb knows him the rally car
in this the newspaper research
[applause]
that's poison  in life itself tord
gustavsen look for she has barbie candan
chica torquay
diekmann pinsky gretchen campbell cic in jamaica
berlin has johnny vogels jack harris
when the whole tour
pulled off bells dry he is dominik schneble the
story the skylink to
the trajectory extreme
[applause
] tempts
christian kern europe even builds a
ricochet nobel prize however it is so
special to win the nobel prize after the
knows hobbit so defective now the
trade anniversary with max sees that
looks negative more specialized
then it starts
after knows orbit trades that is
tradition that on site andreas enough
oil price rally distinguished advises
are sensix iding and has not los because
only wittily says one interprets